[Music]
when you mention the slider of mint I
think about good non anthropocentric Li
what what does that mean
I mean if we think about morality as a
kind of structure that humans have
imposed so I would I would I would pick
up from Michelle says use of grace I
think that some the the the human
devastation of the world would be well
to stop aligning good with action and
bad with passivity or apathy and I think
that you know binary thinking in general
is problematic but grace is lovely
because it is the goodness in stepping
aside and in modern forms of activism
goodness can often come as active
boycott but historically goodness has
come through a sense of hoped for grace
where we simply allow the other to be
without demanding knowledge of the other
without demanding the other come up to
our anthropocentric level of equivalence
so for me maybe there is a deep
unknowability in good that is attractive
because it's difficult but also demands
a very artistic perception of practice
and so in that sense I think it's very
sexy because it's mystical you know
verges on mystical so yeah
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you